[Music]
welcome to a celebratory episode of the
careful boys where we get to talk about
Bart's bodybuilding
competition double gold you did it
double swords double swords even though
I didn't bring the swords I don't know
you asked me yesterday if I brought the
swords why the [__] would I bring the
swords why wouldn't you bring the swords
always bring if I if I won swords I
would travel everywhere with it if DSA
allowed me
he say let you take guns bro but not on
you though can you imagine he's got not
one but two they're heavy and Bart's
traveling the world like this so SI that
would be so cool and he says ask me
about my swords yeah well try the cross
one on your back like Leonardo oh yeah
cool yeah you're like Leonardo look at
that man look keep going keep going back
though almost there yeah I can can't get
it out I can't get my sword yeah you can
Bart like that look at that [__] look at
that [__] do [__] Leo so sick dude
editor can you slow-mo that real quick
cuz that looks I bet it looks
sick also undelete it if you can
remember remember when you first got a
camera when you're like 13 with your
friends and you think that you look cool
as [__] like that dude I did that with
Game Boy
camera you had that yeah that's sick it
was Rad but man what a way to sell a
workout program you win the [__]
bodybuilding competition at the end
that's insane what what made you decide
to actually get
ripped um cuz he's always been strong
yeah I think like sacrificed his
strength for looks and his mind for like
nine months yeah you became like brain
fog Master didn't you brain fog Master
yeah I did have brain I think it was
just one of those things where like um I
don't know when you get old or some [__]
like I I remember like in the last
probably like the last 5 years I've been
like kind of thinking about some of the
things I feel like I could have done
better or things that I regret or
whatever and I'm like when I got into
fitness I always told myself I would
never do a bodybuilding show like people
would ask me and I'm like I would never
do a body just because I don't feel like
I have to discipline for the diet or
whatever and then I started like
thinking about like why do I always say
that like why do I say that like do I
just like hide behind that I'm the the
funny guy in Fitness or whatever like do
I have these crutches which makes me not
really want to do something that's like
really hard and then so last year I
actually like wrote down a bunch of
things that I think I should just do and
then that was one of them I think I
should just get under 10% body fat like
once in my life what do you think was
the limiting belief that kept you
thinking that you you don't want to do
bodybuilding or whatever I think
milkshakes yeah so you're like a food
like your your love for food you you
don't want to give up that on the inside
I'm David I love [__] food David but
two times his appetite like I can eat
David to the ground you can e
so I can eat David to the so like I love
food as much as him but I can also eat
two three times more than he can so I
think so in my mind it's always been
like oh it's not in my DNA or oh I see I
see that's not me right and then but
then I was like but but I'm in control
of who me is or whatever I feel like
when you said you wanted to enter your
40s in the best shape of your life that
was dope yeah and then so I think after
deciding that then I started like
thinking about what are all the positive
things I can come out of and that was
one of them so so it's almost like I
just chose a theme that I said I was I
always said I would can never do just
choose to do it and then now the kind of
like the reverse engineered reasons why
I should do it came after rather than I
think trying to figure out the why and
then choose it was just like just do it
and then the Y will come after yeah did
you know that you were going to win
[__] swords cuz I think if more
competitions had swords as the trophy
that do more competition I I had no idea
and what did the sword have any to do
with the bodybuilding so in that's what
I found out in no no in
bodybuilding they I don't know why it is
but it is cultural across all feder or
Trad traditional they all give you
swords if you win first everyone wants
the sword of the night that's what
everyone goes for so it's like a thinge
yeah how come there's no like Gold Gym
pictures of Arnold Holden swords I don't
know I thought a trophy cuz he doesn't
want to look like Conan again I thought
a trophy was going to be like a regular
soccer trophy and at the top there's
like a gold dude so second place gets a
trophy and then yeah second third get
gets trophies but then first gets swords
that's cool which is kind of cool I
guess you going to mount them yeah
actually am actually so I'm going to
since I got two of them I'm going to get
a a plaque made and I'll get cuz I'm
never going to do it ever again so I
really want to like commemorate it cuz
it was like one of the hardest things
I've ever done in my life and I'm like
okay I'm never going to do this again
I'm glad I got it out of the system and
I did something that I thought I
couldn't do but then inside I am David
so I'm going stick to my roots and uh
not do something like this ever again
yeah I mean you've done a lot of hard
things what made this one extremely hard
so this one is hard for me specifically
it might be hard for other people but so
like boot camp is tough it's 14 weeks of
like hell you only sleep like 5 6 hours
a day um but when you go and eat three
meals a day which is by law they have to
give that to you you're entering into
like a HomeTown Buffet so you can go and
get a stack of six bread you can ask for
like 10 eggs or whatever so I'm one of
those people if I have those things
during my day I can do anything I can
train I can run 20 miles but if if I get
to have four brownies I get to recover
and I feel good so like the fact that
like you can like bust your ass and then
almost kind of fill your cup back up it
makes boot camp a little bit easier and
everyone's doing it and there's no
temptation bodybuilding it's a
self-imposed torture so like when I come
to JK news I see all this too you know
like everyone see is seeing this I have
to tell myself I can't touch that I have
to tell myself I don't want Vietnamese
coffee I have to tell myself I don't
doal with this and I have to come
prepped with my own so it's like almost
like imagine being in jail but it's a
imaginary jail that you impose upon
yourself and that's the part that makes
it really really really hard so that's
like the hard part number one and the
second part that makes it really hard is
once you get towards the last I would
say four weeks of prep your calories are
between for my body weight was between
like 1,00 and 1300 oh wow that's like
one meal yeah so my fats were at 30
which is like the
biological limit before my hair starts
falling out my nail starts cracking
before like the last four weeks of prep
I had no boners in the morning
whatsoever um because your hormones are
just getting saving yeah they're just
it's just gone they literally um they
call it protein sparing starv or protein
sparing fast you're technically doing a
one month fast but only eating enough so
that your cells don't die your body
doesn't die and your muscles don't die
so that you can get like paper thin skin
and so like that part was pretty crazy
like even my barber when I came back
after this show he like dude you're
[__] alive again cuz I kept hearing
that from people like Gio M her her mom
her brother everyone's like dude you
were so [__] dead I was like dude for
real like dead like your energy and the
your think and everything yeah like I
was just the shell of a person no one
was there and then even my Barb was like
dude you're [__] alive again and I
was like what do you mean he goes dude
the last couple times you came in you're
just sitting here like I didn't want to
bug you cuz I know you're going through
prep and I was like what the [__] even
you can tell and I only see you for like
30 minutes at a time yeah so that's
what's that's that's the tough part
where biologically you're starving and
AKA killing yourself but then compared
to like Boot Camp or marathon training
where like Marathon you can run 15 miles
but eat whatever you want after and the
next day you you feel brand new this one
is just like you go 90% 80% 70% so you
feel like a slow death towards the end
and then when you're down there and like
you're like oh like I would the last 3
weeks I would probably wake up five
times every night [__] just from Hunger
cuz you know when your hormones are
[__] you can't even sleep through the
night so I'm like I'm waking up like oh
[__] what the [__] and I'm just sitting
there I'm like God damn it's [__]
3:00 a.m. holy [__] [__] and I'm so
hungry but then I go to the kitchen I
can't really eat anything cuz all my
meals are under 200 calories so I'm like
[__] what do I do what do I [__] do
then you're just kind of like in this
type of like mindset 24 hours a day for
like a whole month think I'm just going
to buy
swords did you tell yourself beauty is
pain I don't even know if I was even
thinking I was just like this is [__]
crazy when you look when you got there
right and you see the guys who came in
second and third did do you look at them
and go like I know why they got
second honestly you do
I didn't I didn't realize that but like
so the difference between so my sport is
actually powerlifting and it's one of
those where like let's say you kind of
had a shitty practice or whatever now I
mean I'm sure even MMA is like this
somehow sometimes you can YOLO a win
right lucky Punch or that one day like
you're about to go up and you're
supposed to squat or deadlift you see
your kid there you get that extra boost
of energy and you're like [__] yeah and
you have that extra superhuman 10% that
kicks in bodybuilding it's all in the
preparation so the day that you show up
you can't magically drop 5% body fat M
there's no YOLO wins it's like a math
test yeah it's like either you're
prepped or not and then so when we
walked in even to this backstage to uh
to get sprayed um my videographer was
like dude I think you might win and I
was like for real I started looking
around and you could just see like the
condition that people came in like Who
had who was leaner who had more like
definition you could just see right then
and they're like generally okay these
guys are top three for sure I'm the most
jacked guy in the
room full the jacked guys those guys can
tell also that they're not going to win
when they look at you and stuff if I was
one of the guys that I saw I would know
I'm not
winning cuz it like that one meme where
the guy's like normal as [__] no there's
this one dude that was there I was like
as this guy is getting sprayed he's
looking rounder and softer oh they put
the town on look more defined and hard
right cuz you're going to go under these
crazy stage lights and it'll just like
wipe you out cuz it's so bright there's
one guy that was getting sprayed and
usually as you get sprayed you just like
you get more and more definition I was
like dude this guy is just turning into
like a Hershey's chocolate bar when they
spray you do they go from just neck down
or all the way the whole thing the whole
thing so even the back of your head your
face how' you feel to be that tan do you
like it it's weird cuz you like you get
sprayed and then you kind of just stand
there and then you have to like wear
pajamas and and a long sleeve shirt to
go to sleep because uh you don't want it
to rub off the next day like on your
sheets you do it the day before yeah you
do it the day before so that's coat
number one coat number two you go in in
the morning again before the show so you
can't shower and then they spray you
down and then right before you go on
stage they do like touch-ups and stuff
damn this video is called like why you
should never do a bodybuilding comp but
you know what's crazy like I I did one
and I was like okay okay [__] that never
doing this again this just [__] crazy
and I talk to people there's people that
do it and they can't wait for the next
one and I ask them I'm like why like
because I I know the last four weeks of
prep is always crazy for every anybody
and the the answer that I get is they go
like when there's no like crazy goal
they feel like they're just kind of
moving aimlessly through life so signing
up for something it locks everything in
and when that part gets locked in so
does their Hustle the relationship like
everything gets locked in so they have
they feel so much focus in their life
and like purpose and purpose so they
can't wait to have that feeling again
instead of just Meandering around I'm
like oh [__] okay I see I can see why
people would do it but I would never do
it again okay next question you're done
with the competition first thing you
eat was it so the so during the I don't
know why but I had like uh urges for
Smash Burger like a really good crispy
meat with the cheese Smashburger with
the Fluffy bread and then um peanut
butter jelly sandwiches so that sounds
bomb too yeah so I uh at the same time
no those are just my two random urges
stacked up yeah so I uh I I uh yelped
around the the bodybuilding show like if
there was a Smash burger place I found a
place that had four stars was actually
pretty good directly after the show yeah
right after the show we're going there
wow I got I got one Burger fry and a
milkshake and I was like see life is
about balance I'm just going to get one
Burger I us I'm a two Burger guy I'm
just get one Burger so I got one Burger
I bit into it I was like God thisam is
[__] good I stood up and I went to
order another
[Laughter]
one incredible so I had two burgers a
milkshake fries and then I got home and
I immediately made like two peanut
butter jelly sandwiches that was so good
they taste better than anything ever cuz
you've just been so deprived yeah like
all your taste buds were like yeah
because you're you're um you're eating
single ingredient be it's like this is
like like 20 ingredients right you're
eating like chicken yeah with no salt
sace nothing some some days no salt cuz
you don't can't have any sodium so it's
like just chicken or [__]
broccoli just base food what was the
best was it like that moment that you
ate cereal was it that moment you at the
smash BRD honestly it was a cereal the
cereal video was was it the cereal
before yeah so the cereal um it was
because so you get crazy depleted um
your muscles will look flat so so
there's a carb up day leading into the
show and then so on carb up day my coach
Jared CH jar who's coming on in like 2
weeks he's prescribed me a think like
800 gam of carbs and and he'll literally
write out the meal plan so you don't
[__] around it'll be like uh 250 g of
carbs from a kid's cereal so I was like
[__] yeah cinnamon toes crunch I dumped
literally like half the box cuz I was
doing the calculation I was like how
much ises 250 g of carbs from this and
it was half the box I was like [__] yeah
and then just eating that it was like
Flavor Nostalgia childhood everything
like all at once and I was like
oh what was the crazier feeling that or
sex your first
time like as a 15-year-old or like your
first time first time oh cuz I didn't
have a boner for a month I was like I
didn't know if you meant first times
having sex coming back I see coming back
from like now or a
15-year-old whichever one was crazier
which one's crazier whichever is more
comparable to the bowl of cereal yeah to
the bowl of cereal dude that's [__]
crazy he's like I'm going to say the
cereal I think cinnamon to grunt for
both that's eating it and then like
feeling [__] Goosebumps down my back
like
wow I it's probably the sugar too yeah I
think I was looking my lips watching you
eat it cuz I never seen such like
[__] Happ funny dude you explaining
your process of finding the Burger Joint
I could see your mouth like salivating
you're like yeah then [__] that F looked
like he farted and came at the same
time no cuz cuz like yeah when I was
like uh about to make the cereal I was
like I think I should record this cuz I
haven't I don't even know I haven't had
cereal in [__] hella long you know I
haven't even had rice in like 4 months
like white rice that would kill me so I
was like I'm surprised you didn't get
like a crazy insulin spike in like fuel
[__]
up I think I just had an orgasm or
whatever it is like a shot of I just
nutted that's all it came out in his nut
and what's crazy is that day I had 800 G
of cars and you know just uh dry carb
weight will hold water you know like
when you eat like let's say a bowl of f
the next day you'll weigh 2 lbs heavier
because it just holds water I was like
oh [__] I think my weight's going to get
[__] up tomorrow I stepped on the
scale and my weight didn't change I
think my body just like evaporated yeah
I was like did you gain 40 lbs that was
like the next day yeah the next I gained
20 lb so I was I weighed in at 168 for
the show the next day after the Smash
Burgers and peanut butter jelly and then
then we drove back from LA to Vegas we
stopped by Eddie's world I had two whole
pizzas a bag of two whole pizza yeah and
I had a bag of uh yogurt covered
pretzels holy [__] a back well cuz you
know when you're just driving and eating
you just go through the B and then I had
uh after two old pizzas exactly how big
is a whole pizza by the way this big
like a medium oh and then I had a chili
cheese dog and then some peanut brittle
it's like Eddie Eddie's World kind of
candy and then the next day I woke up
and I was like I wonder how heavy I am
I'm like maybe like 5 lbs heavier and I
stood on there and I was like what the
[__]
187 two and and that was just all food
well so that's my so this is why it's
really dope to have a coach so that you
don't [__] panic and freak out all
the time like I was like yo what the
[__] going on cuz my goal was I'm
going to do this show I'm going stay 10%
body like I went down to about like 7%
body fat I'll stay 10% body fat that's
what I'm going to maintain and then my
next my next uh phase of my life I want
to get into Jiu-Jitsu and I looked at
the weight classes and 180 you have to
waigh in with the G so 175 177 was going
to be perfect I'm just going to maintain
this I didn't think I was going to
balloon up to 187 so I text him Y what
the [__] going on and he goes oh
that's uh called the sodium carb rebound
and it's not that like this is your
actual weight it's just your body is so
diminished that it's going to retain
everything and it'll take about two
weeks to correct itself so even a week
after the bodybuilding show I had like
the the most insane headaches the entire
week cuz my sodium and electrolytes are
so off so it's almost like my body has
been walking through a desert for a
month and then so even when if I'm
drinking water my body's not maintaining
the it's not holding on to the water so
I was like having the craziest headaches
you low don't worry that's normal I'm
like man [__] are crazy like
doing this kind [__] ni dude if you ate
all that but then also had a salad
you've been fine yeah that's why I
didn't have a salad that's why your head
was hurting the the only other time when
you were talking about your weight loss
in general that I was like this is
bananas was when Joe was like this is
the first time in my life where Bart
weighs less than me yeah yeah and our
friend history it's never happened yeah
he's always been bigger by a lot dude
seeing you at that weight was a trip cuz
it's like you still were able to keep
your muscle mass but then you're just
like a smaller version and you're like
what the your chair looked bigger like
like JK chair looked bigger around you
yeah yeah yeah I'm just not used to huge
there's that constant progression where
we would go on walks and you always take
off your shirt and just like every now
and then we just always get more turned
on by you and it was really weird cuz
it's crazy
bro whistle especially like 233 when the
sun's hitting just right it's like w
Bart's looking good we're over here
biting our lips dude well congrats buddy
that was awesome thank
thank you so the two swords you won was
it in two different weight classes or
like how did that happen there's two
divisions so I signed up for like you
could do like different competitions in
the same competition so one I signed up
for debut which is you've never done a
bodybuilding show before uh so I did I
did that um division then I also did um
novice novice means you've done a
bodybuilding show but you've never
placed so I would say novice is so like
debut is almost like first-time beginner
sorry my logic calendar is or meter
going off right now so you've never done
it before but then you sign up for
another one well you have done it
before what do you mean no never placed
never placed never placed but isn't the
debut one you've never done it before
that one I never did before novice is
anybody can do it if you haven't placed
so you do debate debut first we all got
so the debut counts as the novice got it
well so I have to pose twice I go and I
pose for debut never done it before and
it was like me and I think like two
other people and then novice was was
more stacked it was like five people and
then that's if you have never placed
before so if you've done a competition
but you got fifth place or sixth place
or seventh place then you do that so you
qualify for both yeah and then after
that um the next division like if I were
to do it again then I would have to do
this one called open and then it would
be like novice would be almost be like
amateurs and then open would be like uh
like Amro like very seasoned amateur to
Pro and then the next goal after that
would be try to get like a pro card or
whatever that's kind of like how it how
it Raks up but I don't think B going to
get his Pro card you guys I would never
it's too crazy is there any like workout
program out there where the guy wins a
[__] bodybuilding championship at the
end that's crazy are you the first one
to make something like that oh I don't
know I even think about it like because
to me that's the craziest thing is that
there I don't I never see workout
programs where somebody puts up that
high of a bet and like cashes it in at
the end I didn't even feel like that
like from Power Li to that's how good
the program is the program's so good
like who would say no to that program
the guy freaking wins and he's done it
all natural but then he makes a whole
video where he [__] hates to
experience and would never do it
again yeah cuz I didn't even wow I
didn't even feel like the way I viewed
it was just like oh this is a cool
Journey let's go do it I don't know how
people call us marketing genus that's
the part that I'm seeing that I'm like
wao because you see all these
influencers with their workout programs
and it's just a bunch of like fluff but
like you're actually like all right come
with me on this and see how it goes I
thought that's why you did the show
yeah guys who swim in Lakes they they
swim like back and forth on across whole
leges I trust those
guys